lucy ricardo  will be pregnant on the show  and eight episode arc  starting with lucy telling ricky the  happy news and ending with the birth of  the baby  no no you can't have a pregnant woman on  television why not because it's  television we come into people's homes  pregnant women often vomit i know i  could any second may i say something  frankly i can't if lucy ricardo's  pregnant the audience's mind immediately  goes to how did she get that way lucy  and ricky sleep in separate beds we'll  be pushing the best together too oh no  no no no no no i'm sorry dez we're gonna  have to put our foot down on this one  you can't do it end of discussion  [Music]  you